quelque chose s'est passé pendant leur
mission spatiale
pourquoi avez vous besoin de moi
j'ai besoin de votre expertise
pouvez vous me dire pourquoi ils ne
retiennent ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
cette chose vie en lui n'en a pas
conscience
votre mission est de séparer le parasite
de l'hôte
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent de moi si vous
avez besoin de moi pourquoi moi que chez
vous certaines choses si cette chaud
s'échappe tout le monde moore ce que
nous accomplissons est plus grand que
tout cela cela serait un sacrifice
nécessaire
j'aurais dû vous dire la vérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
courez vous ne savez rien de moi lui a
tant de choses qu'on ignore sur nous
mêmes